-Thank you so much.
-Goodness, so nice to be here.
Thank you so much.
-Dude, look at that.
They love you.
We all love you.
How's that feel?
When the audience --
-It feels crazy.
I mean, this is the first time
I've been on a TV show
in, you know,
a year and a half or whatever.
Right? In a room
with a bunch of people.
-Yeah, it's bizarre.
-It's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy too.
Thanks for having me. Thank you.
-Every time you come on,
and thank you
for doing our show,
I mean, doing all those --
it was just crazy times.
You were saying of course
you were getting back to work.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But everything was shut down.
And you were -- you said that
you changed your laundry room
into like 10 different rooms.
-We were -- We were in
our little tiny house
out in Long Island.
-Yup.
-Just me and my husband
and our teenage daughter.
And we only had one little space
where we could all work,
and that was the laundry room,
and it was also where
my husband's office was,
and it was where I did yoga.
It's where my daughter
did homework.
That's where I recorded
an animated movie.
In this laundry room.
-Wow. Did you really?
-Yeah, yeah.
And they would be like,
"Do you have a space
that's a little less live?
A little less echoey?"
I'm like, "No."
-No.
-"This is it."
-Everyone found a new room
during this whole thing.
-We'd stick towels under
the door. Yeah, this is it.
And we'd rotate in and out of
there, 'cause yeah, you know.
-Wait. Is this spirit?
Is that --
-"Spirit Untamed."
Yeah.
I've read about this.
-Your daughters will love this.
-My kids are into "Spirit."
They love "Spirit."
-Yeah, they love horses
and all that.
-Yeah.
-Next Friday,
your new series,
"Lisey's Story," comes out.
-Mm-hmm.
-This is Stephen King.
-Stephen King, yeah.
-This is not your first foray
into scary.
-No. It's not my first
scary-movie event.
-No, your first scary movie
was -- Everyone remembers.
-Oh, sure.
You'll remember this one.
-"Tales From the Dark Side,"
the movie.
Look at you there.
-Yeah. That's me. That's me.
-Now that is you
somewhere under there?
-[ Laughs ]
-And what do you remember
about this?
-Well, you know what's
interesting about this
is that this is the part
of the movie --
I really remember this because
this is a part of the movie
that I didn't think
that I was in.
It was my first movie,
this horror movie,
and we were shooting it
in Yonkers.
I was so excited
to get this horror movie.
-Yeah.
-And I have a tendency even now
not to read anything
but the dialogue,
you know, when I get a script.
Because I don't like
stage directions.
I don't like hearing, you know,
"She walks down the street
jauntily."
I know
I'll walk down the street.
I might not be jaunty.
I don't want to know
what they think.
-Yeah, you're acting.
-I'm gonna figure it out.
Right? So I don't read
any of the stage directions.
So on this job,
it was a really quick job,
I finished, and I got killed
by the mummy,
and I went over to the director
to say good-bye
and thank you for this
great opportunity.
And he was like,
"You're not done."
[ Light laughter ]
I'm like "No,
this is my last scene."
He goes, "No, no.
You didn't finish reading
the script, did you?"
Because -- Because I turn
into a mummy at the end.
-Yeah, come back.
-And I come back
and I kill somebody else.
But it was all
in stage directions,
and I never read it.
So it was so incredibly
unprofessional of me.
-But look at you --
-I didn't read the script.
-Yeah, but look at you now.
It's all worked out.
I lost my voice
earlier in the week.
-It sounds good.
Sounds sexy.
-It is sexy, right?
-Yeah. Sexy voice.
-Thank you.
Please tell my wife that.
-Sexy Fallon.
-Yeah, thank you.
What would that be like,
sexy Fallon?
But you've screamed before.
Do you have any tips?
-You can't scream
without losing your voice.
-You just can't?
-I would have to --
The director of "Lisey's Story"
would always --
I would say, "Please save
the screaming
that you want me to do
until Friday night,
because I'm going to need
two days to recover,"
because I'd always blow out
my voice,
and I wanted it to be better
on a Monday.
But then, like --
so every Friday,
he'd be like, "You ready?
We're gonna do some screaming."
But this one weekend,
I had an audition
for "Dear Evan Hansen"
the next day.
So he was like --
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yeah.
So he was like, "Scream."
And I'm like,
"I don't want to scream."
He's like, "Scream."
And I was like, aaaaah.
[ Laughter ]
-"That's your scream?"
Aaaah.
-I was like...
♪ I have an audition ♪
♪ I can't blow out my voice ♪
-Yeah.
How'd the audition go?
-I mean, you know, hopefully
it didn't sound like that.
-Yeah.
-I did get the job.
-You got the part. Yeah.
-I got the job.
So that was great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I saw the trailer.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-The trailer came out --
-Such a good trailer, right?
-Oh, dude, that guy.
-And Ben Platt is a genius.
-Ben Platt is insane.
"Lisey's Story."
-Yeah.
-This is based on a Stephen King
book, very popular.
How do we describe it?
-Okay. So Lisey is a woman
who's married to a famous writer
who has -- at the beginning of
the story,
you realize he's been dead
for a couple of years.
And so she's kind of
living her life by herself,
but she's getting all these
weird messages from her past.
At the same time,
this other guy,
one of her husband's fans --
he's a horror writer --
is stalking her.
So it's kind of
a really complicated
psychological horror drama.
It's good.
-Of course it is. Yeah.
It's on Apple TV Plus.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Julianne Moore
in "Lisey's Story."
Take a look.
-Funny that you --
that you came today
'cause I was just looking
at your picture
in the Horlick's yearbook.
Picture of the hero who saves
a famous writer's life,
but, um, I think reality,
you ran like a rabbit.
-Mrs. Landon.
-You came back, though,
to get your picture taken
and to grab the credit.
I mean, I don't care about that.
I never cared about credit.
I don't care about that at all,
but you are not
getting in there,
and you are never
going to see his papers.
-You were nothing but
a restaurant hostess
when you caught his eye.
The fact
that you slept in his bed
does not give you the right to
withhold his unwritten papers
from the rest of the world.
-Oh, my God.
-Julianne Moore, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think I just --
-Spit everywhere.
-"Lisey's Story" premieres
Friday, June 4th
on Apple TV Plus.